ces mesures de confinement ne seront pas
la reprise telle quelle de celle que
nous avions mise en place en mars et en
novembre dernier
jeudi dernier à l'annoncé des nouvelles
mesures décidées pour tenter d'enrayer
l'épidémie
jean castex avait parlé de confinement
pourtant au sein du gouvernement le
premier ministre paraît bien isolé
le lendemain vendredi emmanuel macron a
lui même refusé d'assimiler ces
nouvelles restrictions à un confinement
une position également partagée ce
dimanche par le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand je me refuse à parler de
confinement tout simplement parce que ce
n'en est pas un si je devais improvisé
un slogan ce serait serré pour souffler
se distancier pour se protéger pour
autoriser les français des 16
départements concernés à se déplacer le
ministère de l'intérieur à samedi matin
mis en ligne une nouvelle attestation
dérogatoire rédigé sur deux pages et
comportant pas moins de 15 motifs de
sorties dont neuf marqués d'une * ce
document semblait bien loin de la clarté
que souhaitez faire prévaloir jean
castex cette nouvelle attestation de
déplacement a été vivement moqué sur les
réseaux sociaux
le temps de remplir ton attestations et
c'est déjà le couvre-feu dès le 26 mars
à minuit nous mettrons en place des
cours pédagogiques en ligne afin de
pouvoir comprendre la nouvelle
attestation reconnue comme complexe par
la porte parole du ministère de
l'intérieur
cette attestation a rapidement été
supprimé par le gouvernement
l'exécutif a décidé de changer ses plans
pour les déplacements entre 6 heures et
19 heures à moins de 10 kilomètres il a
finalement opté pour la présentation
d'un justificatif de domicile
des versions dérogatoire un peu plus
allégée ont également été adoptées pour
les déplacements supérieure à 10 km et
aux heures de couvre-feu